let's go to our next caller from the
6:00 to 6:00 area code who's calling
today from 6:00 to 6:00
hello David this is Ramon hey Ramon okay
so I have a question regarding Trump's
support you coming for the 2020 election
now I know that he has a strong base and
they are very much very committed to him
I would say drinking the orange flavored
kool-aid
yes but check this out though I saw an
article very recently that with Trump
how he is with his lack of immorality
advocacy and how he's handling the
recent events such as mass shootings
lack of gun control and the tariff war
with China
I read that he could be moving some kind
of support whether it's someone from
people from those who vote him back in
2016 and thought that he's not doing
much a good job or those who voted for
him who have a moral standards or the
feel that he's not with me up to that
kind of morality or independence as a
whole who I believe that he really needs
to be reelected especially in the Rust
Belt states so I want to know if you
have any kind of bomb if you see
something like that or where your take
is about his support community for 2020
I mean listen it's so what you're saying
something that's qualitative which I
appreciate which is there are farmers
who are realizing that Trump's tariffs
are crushing them we played a clip
earlier this week of a mom and daughter
who vote in Iowa and they're Republicans
but they can't vote for Trump because
they think he's crazy on immigration
like qualitatively yeah that there are
people who are Republicans and voted
Trump in 2016 who are not going to vote
Trump in 2020 the thing is it's like so
what in the sense of that there's no
strategy around that right if people are
on the right and they've decided I can't
vote for Trump again then that's great
they're not voting for Trump they're
already sort of out of the equation
then it's just a matter of what is it
that the Democratic Party and eventual
candidate can
due to defeat Trump and it's get people
to vote find people who already agree
with you but might not be planning to
vote and get them to vote so I don't
know what the numbers are of what you're
talking about
there are trumpets from 2016 who won't
be voting Trump in 2020 there are
probably some people who didn't even
vote at all in 2016 who now love Trump
and are going to vote I just think that
it's a non-factor in terms of strategy
because the strategy never was to
convince Trump voters to change their
minds it's some of them will some won't
we've got to get our base out if that
makes sense yeah that leads me to my
next question this regarding former
governor former representative mark
Sanford who he had expressed interest in
running for president against Trump in
the GOP primary yeah now I don't know if
he's gonna run as a GOP for the GOP
ticket or I'll know he runs a third
party as a third party but if you can
recall back in 1992 when Ross Perot the
late Ross Perot now he ran as a third
party and it hurt George HW Bush during
the election do you think that may have
the same effect or a very similar effect
if he did so I don't know that Sanford
specifically is the guy to have that
effect but yeah I mean mathematically I
would love a strong primary challenge to
Trump because it would just delay the
amount of time it would delay when he
can really start focusing on running the
general if he's running a primary so I
would love that if someone runs third
party and can actually get to three
percent of the vote that would pull
Republican votes that would be
absolutely fantastic and it could
literally be the difference maker and
defeating Trump in 2020 so I'm for all
of that stuff as long as you know I'm
not gonna support someone where it's
less clear who they're taking votes from
like the Howard Schultz thing there was
disagreement over who would Howard
Schultz have taken more votes from the
Democratic nominee or Trump different
people at different ideas if there's a
Republican running third party who
clearly will hurt Trump I'm all for that
100% all right now one quick questions
it's very quick okay I'm not yet a
member but yeah have your personal
authorization personal permission to
become a member of the
pakkun show yep oh you're completely you
you I've authorized you fully to buy a
hundred memberships for yourself yeah
yeah cuz I have you on the line of these
will ask you good yep no I'm completely
for that and I look forward to welcoming
you as a member okay alright okay thanks
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you